moi
rando pays vous propose cette semaine
une émission spéciale pour en apprendre
un peu plus sur les espèces exotiques
envahissantes en compagnie du
naturaliste joël dupont elles se
multiplient très vite ont souvent des
couleurs remarquables sont parfois très
apprécié les espèces exotiques
envahissantes qui jalonnent nos sentiers
ont colonisé toute l'île et sont devenus
la principale menace des milieux
naturels
mais de quoi s'agit-il exactement
à la réunion comme partout dans le monde
l'homme a toujours introduit des espèces
pour différents usages
ces espèces dites exotiques
c'est à dire étrangères à lille au
départ se comptent aujourd'hui par
milliers
une partie d'entre elles en moyenne une
sur dix sont naturalisés c'est à dire
qu'elle réussisse à se reproduire à
l'état sauvage sans l'intervention de
l'homme
parmi ces espèces naturalisées il arrive
que certaines se développe de manière
anarchique et deviennent envahissantes
un problème que l'on peut retrouver
partout dans le monde mais d'autant plus
fort dans un milieu insulaire où la
compétition écologique est par nature
plus faibles la pression sélective dans
les îles est beaucoup moindre que sur
les espaces continentaux donc les
espèces qui ont évolué avec une pression
sélective moindre si vous voulez tant
qu'elle était en 13 ça allait m'aider
quand elles sont confrontées à des
espèces introduites par l'homme qui l
ont évolué dans un contexte où la
pression sélective été extrêmement forte
ces espèces donc introduites sont
puissamment armé pour faire face à la
concurrence et tout et les espèces
insulaires face à ces espèces
introduites sont beaucoup plus sont
beaucoup moins compétitives et elles se
font assez souvent submergé le brun
geôliers marron l'ajonc d'europe la
jouvence le long gosse le raisin marron
sont autant d'espèces qui pullulent dans
nos forêts à l' équilibre dans leur
milieu d'origine
elles ont trouvé à la réunion des
conditions idéales pour se développer au
détriment de toutes les autres espèces
pays -la plus virulents d'entre elle est
aussi la plus controversée
le goyavier dire que le goyavier d'une
peste végétale
alors déjà il faut se départir de la
vision anthropocentriste pour l'homme le
gorille est une plante 8il moi même lire
a menacé trois kilos de goyavier hier
mais pour la nature c'est une
catastrophe
c'est la pire peste végétale c'est celle
qui progresse le plus vite et qu'ils
occupent les plus grandes surfaces à la
réunion la conséquence du développement
de ces espèces envahissantes c'est
l'appauvrissement des milieux car ces
espèces ne partage pas quand l'espace
est disponible elle occupe au détriment
des autres à terme le risque c'est ni
plus ni moins que la disparition totale
d'espèces et d'habitats pays
dans les îles dès que l'homme détruit
des habitats ce qui vient à la place ce
sont que des exotiques
sauf exception et la faune qu'on y
trouve que ce soit les insectes les
mollusques les oiseaux sq ont dans leur
grande majorité également des exotiques
d'ailleurs je ne suis plus qu'à
scientifique a dit quelles sont les
causes de disparition nique de diversité
dans le monde c'est d'abord la
destruction des habitats et deuxièmement
les invasions biologiques mais dans les
îles
c'est le facteur numéro 2 donc les
invasions qui devient le facteur
prépondérant
aujourd'hui les moyens de lutte sont
minimes la vitesse de renouvellement et
de propagation de ces espèces étant bien
trop rapide dans certains cas des
solutions efficaces mais controversées
ont été employées comme l'introduction
d'un prédateur naturel
les larves de la mouche bleue contre le
raisin marron mais sur le fond on est
surtout démunis une invasion elle doit
être prise au début pour les invasions
que sont déjà bien installés
malheureusement les connaissances que
nous avons les moyens actuellement ne
permettent qu'une lutte fragmentaire sur
les petits endroits mais qu'il faudrait
cependant le problème à bras le corps
une prise de conscience et puis mettre
le paquet pour voir peut-être que la
science dans l'avenir nous donnera les
moyens de lutter efficacement confais
contre ces espèces là qu'elle soit
animale ou végétale
l'autre facteur limitant c'est que ce
problème d'évasion biologique et méconnu
du grand public et que les enjeux de
préservation du patrimoine naturel de
l'île ne sont pas forcément évident pour
tous souvent on emploie des arguments et
kimi tarifs pour le justifier en disant
ah oui mais toutes ces plantes qui
disparaît peut-être qu'on pourrait en
retirer des médicaments esterra oui
c'est vrai mais pour moi c'est pas ça le
plus important
c'est une question de
je dirais plus philosophique à quoi ça
sert de garder la cadre de notre dame de
paris on ferait mieux de la en
l'air et me faire un parking à là place
à quoi ça sert de garder la langue
créole autant parler français voire
anglais c'est plus utile
voyez si on raisonne toujours en termes
d'utilité rythme va jamais on pourra
prendre conscience de ça parce
qu'effectivement il n'y a pas de notion
utilitarisme dedans malgré cette menace
grandissante la nature réunionnaise est
encore splendide
alors continuez de la découvrir et d'en
profiter en parcourant les sentiers de
l'île